news now investigators the only ones in
court as a man is formally charged with
murder now that man accused of pushing a
security officer causing him to to
develop a brain bleed which later killed
him David Charles broke the story last
week and he filed this report from point
sir
35 year old Pedro Lozano first tells a
judge he killed how Cortez security
officer Randy Lyons last September
he then changed his plea when he pushed
him Randy fell backwards and hid his
head on the concrete
which uh
caused an immediate brain bleed
Elizabeth McDowell was married to lions
for 11 years I went to pick him up from
work and he wasn't coming out he wasn't
coming out he wasn't coming out I'm like
what's going you know what's going on
police say Lozano shud lions in the
hotels valet causing him to fall
backward and hit his head doctors told
McDowell Lions would never be the same
and may not survive five months later
she made the difficult decision to take
him off life support and I said and I'm
gonna miss you but this is the best
thing for you and he squeezed my hand
like he understood Lozano was first
charged with Valerie and as the 8 news
now investigators first reported last
week that charge now upgraded to murder
I don't hate him
but I can't forgive him right now Lozano
is being held without bail he will be in
court again next week at the Regional
Justice Center on David Jones 8 news now
David thank you for that well that
murder charges enhanced due to Lion's
age and he did plead not guilty